thanks for joining us America I'm glad
you're here this is the Dave Ramsey show
common sense or your dollars in a sense
Jones with us in Baltimore hi Joan how
are you I'm fine Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up okay so I took
your financial piece class in the fall
and learn so much and I'm about ready to
start my first class on Sunday as a
matter of fact and the sad part about it
is I can't convince my rockhead daughter
to like listen to these learn these
lessons that I've learned she just
graduated from college she has been
wounded she's got about four thousand
dollars in credit card debt she just got
a car etc and she wants it all and she
wants it now but that doesn't work and
so I'm trying to get her to like rework
her budget and try to come up with a way
to like knock this debt out while she's
still living with me because you know I
don't want that to happen for too much
longer and um I was wondering if you
could proud you know try to help me and
give her like an estimate like two years
a year you know but she's obviously got
to stick with it but she doesn't even
want an estimate mhm but you know she
will listen if I you know I give her
some hard numbers she hasn't listened
before why would she no no I don't know
I keep praying and hoping
oh she's 25 okay and what does she make
a year she just started she's making
thirty a year how much did she borrow on
her car okay so the car is 15,000 okay I
know much as her student loans her
student loans are 46,000 and then she
has about 46 in credit card
4640 640 X thousand for sure oh no 4,600
okay so fifty fifty sixty five thousand
dollars making thirty thousand dollars a
year
and she bought a car she couldn't afford
against your wishes are you married well
actually actually I'm a widow
okay I mean actually I actually want you
know actually she was actually in a car
and totaled it so she didn't want to
have to buy a car but you know know what
I told her she had about $15,000 car
well true I tried to get her to buy like
a six thousand like what the insurance
was front of hair but you're right yeah
so she bought a car she couldn't afford
because you can't afford a $15,000 car
when you make thirty thousand dollars a
year with forty six thousand dollars in
student loan debt that's insanity right
so she's and then she's making a mistake
of putting like three hundred into
savings and of course then she doesn't
have enough money then in month and wise
up calling it back out again so on I
have a 26 year old son I was getting
married soon okay but if this if he were
in exactly the situation with exactly
this behaviors or if one of my daughter
is wearing exactly the situation with
exactly these behaviors here's how we
would handle it at the Ramsey house okay
that's how I know how to answer
questions there's only what would I do
if I were in your shoes okay I would sit
down and say I am really sorry I've not
done a good job making sure you knew how
to handle money and you are making so
many mistakes it terrorizes me for your
future I love you and I'm so scared for
your future because you were being
unbelievably stupid and it's my fault
because I didn't teach you so I'm
apologizing for you to you for that
that's the good news
the bad news is is that I'm gonna start
requiring some things of you for your
own good
and so if you are going to stay here
under my roof you are going to do two
things you're going to put your car up
for sale and move into a car that you
can afford and you're going to go
through Financial Peace University if
you're unwilling to do that
you have 30 days to move and I would
throw one out I would throw her out
maybe that's the only way she'll
actually get them nothing because she
you're enabling her
you know you're participating in her
crazy when you give her a free place to
live while she's being stupid and it's
not good for her it's not harming you
and I'm not suggesting you be mean I'm
suggesting you'd be very kind gentle but
firm because the question you need to
ask yourself anytime you're dealing with
anyone you love is how can I help them
be the best version of themselves five
years from now and ten years from now is
it to make them uncomfortable today so
that they stop doing self-destructive
behavior the answer is yes I want to
make them uncomfortable today so they
stop doing self-destructive behavior I
you know when my kids were teenagers I
used to remind them all the time my job
is not to be your friend and so I really
don't care if you're mad at me okay yeah
I can live with you being mad at me
because I love you so much that I'm not
going to participate in your
self-destructive behavior I love you so
much I'm willing to let you be angry
with me for your own good
does that make sense yes it surely does
yeah it's about you being loving and
strong it's not about you being a bully
or mean or yelling or calling somebody
names or something like that this is
just well that's not my mo anyway no and
I can tell you're just a just a very
nice person and I'm trying to say it's
okay to be a nice person and also part
of being a nice person is to want what's
best for everyone
and cause it to happen right instead of
like trying to fix it you want this more
than she wants it right now yeah that's
true that is that's what cuz I can see
where it's going to end up with her yeah
she's got a decade of pain ahead of her
if she doesn't change these habits you
and I can see that hey I've been stupid
- I got a pH D and D U and B that's how
I can see it you know you've made
mistakes that's how you can see it right
sixty-three years or hoarse and mistakes
are you doing now get this straight so
yeah I don't want to go through what I
went through I would just start it with
an apology I wish I had taught you
better I didn't know I'm so sorry
and I love you and I love you so much
that I am at this point I'm no longer
gonna participate in your decisions that
are gonna bring you harm I love you so
much I'm not gonna give you a drink
you're an alcoholic I'm not gonna
participate in your behaviors that in
bring you harm and so you're going to
start doing some smart things with money
for your own good
or you're gonna be on your own figuring
it out because I'm not gonna give you a
place to live if you're gonna be crazy
and it's not because I don't love you
it's because I do love you and this is
how the conversation goes and that's how
it would go down at the Ramsey house now
I don't know exactly how it'll go down
at Joan's house you can decide what you
want to do but that that's that's how we
do it and and so you know but we don't
have any grown kids living at home going
into debt and we're having grown kids
living at home doing drugs we don't have
any grown kids at home that refuse to
work we don't have any grown kids at
home thank you Lord we did to see them
when they let us see the babies hey
we've all been there the book is smart
money smart kids hold on I'll give you a
copy Joan was written with my daughter
Rachel and I and her from the grown
daughters perspective who had to endure
being Dave Ramsey's daughter Lord helped
my children right and and from the dads
mean old daddy's perspective yeah but
it's how to teach your kids how to
handle money smart money smart kids and
that way they can grow up and be
productive and you know have a good life
because they make better decisions and
it's you know it's the stuff we teach
them those of us that are loving parents
when we know to teach them and sometimes
you don't know what to do but this is
this is how you teach your kids from age
3 to age 33 how to handle money and how
to make these decisions like we're doing
right here ok that's tough love no it's
just love it's just love it's not any
kind of love to participate in someone's
misbehavior and support it financially
that's gonna bring them harm how can you
call that love it's called enabling it's
a toxic behavior and so it's not tough
love it's just love and is it tough love
make your kid brush their teeth so they
have some it's not tough love is it
tough love to make them do their
homework so they can get through school
and have an academic ability to do
critical thought or ability to learn no
not tough love no it's just it's just
love discipline is part of love guiding
people gently firmly lovingly kindly as
part of love firmly though is a complete
sentence this is the Dave Ramsey show